dans mes tout de suite tout de suite et
bien le premier volet du dossier spécial
non effets spéciaux pardon c'est un
sujet très intéressant il faut donc dire
précisément que ça s'appelle les effets
spéciaux du cinéma et de la télévision
cela va vous être présenté par nicolas
hulot dont vous allez faire tout de
suite la connaissance voilà bien venu
effectivement dans les dossiers de ces
visiteurs dit mercredi dossier qu'on
retrouvera régulièrement au cours
desquelles nous traiteront de sujets et
d'autres mais je dois je dois vous dire
tout de suite que nous allons parler
pendant quatre semaines et je rentre
tout de suite dans la matière d'un sujet
sur lequel nous reviendrons donc dans
quatre semaines autant vous dire que
c'est un sujet très intéressant de quoi
allons nous parler eh bien nous allons
parler des effets spéciaux ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler les effets spéciaux
c'est un petit peu la magie du cinéma la
magie du film et pour ce faire pour
parler de ses effets spéciaux et bien je
vous propose deux choses tout d'abord
nous avons reçu de walt disney cette
super maison de production américaine
eh bien nous avons reçu d une série de
quatre films que nous verrons
successivement donc durant ces quatre
semaines et vous verrez au travers de
ces quatre séries de films au cours
desquelles d'ailleurs vous retrouverez
des personnages de ces héros dessinés de
ses dessins animés de walt disney a
rendu célèbre et puis nous retrouverons
des xxii extraits de films de films de
walt disney qui sont déjà parus ou qui
vont paraître
et puis également nous aurons avec tout
daniel vieille mère je ne vous en dit
pas trop sur lui je vous dirai seulement
que d'habitude il n'est pas à cet
endroit du plateau il est plutôt
derrière nous en régie elle et lui mère
est ce qu'on appelle dans notre métier
un truc listées dans les visiteurs du
mercredi ils opèrent souvent dans ces
petits trucs dans cette magie du cinéma
et de la télévision
alors je ne vous en dis pas plus sachez
seulement qu'on va voir tout de suite
l'un de ces de ses premiers à l'une de
ses premières séries de ces quatre films
de walt disney alors je vous demande de
prêter toute votre attention car vous
allez voir les effets spéciaux se
déroule en cascade à leurs tâches et de
nos manques et rock